[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
et au sénat avec à mes côtés oriane
monsigny bonjour oriane xativa est notre
invité cette semaine et loïc hervé
sénateur union centriste de la
haute-savoie bonjour bonjour et cette
semaine parlement a définitivement
adopté la loi anti casseurs après un
vote conforme du sénat
une partie de l'opposition la juge
dangereuse et liberticide et fait rare
emmanuel macron a lui même saisi le
conseil constitutionnel sur ce texte
la privatisation d'aéroports de paris
continue de faire du bruit au parlement
après un rejet du sénat elle a été de
nouveau voté jeudi soir à l'assemblée
nationale
et malgré les quelques concessions de
bruno le maire droite et gauche réunies
continue de crier leur opposition
quel sort sera réservé au parlement dans
les conclusions du grand débat parmi les
propositions des français certaines
concernent les parlementaires comme la
baisse de leur nombre et avant même la
fin de ce grand débat richard ferrand a
annoncé cette semaine plusieurs réformes
concernant l'assemblée nationale
et on commence cette semaine avec la loi
anti-casseurs définitivement adopté par
le parlement le texte issu du sénat a
été voté conforme par les sénateurs
mardi soir malgré les modifications
apportées à l'assemblée nationale cette
loi instaure un délit de dissimulation
du visage des fouilles des interdictions
préventive de manifester une partie de
l'opposition la jugent liberticide
la gauche a saisi le conseil
constitutionnel tout comme le chef de
l'état jonathan dupriez et fabrice
qu'une et 210 voix contre 115 et 18
abstentions
mardi soir en séance publique les
sénateurs ont définitivement adopté la
loi anti-casseurs un vote conforme avec
l'assemblée nationale à l'origine de ce
texte le sénateur bruno retailleau
on ne parvient plus désormais à
manifester pacifiquement
chaque manifestation chaque grande
manifestation fait l'objet d'une traque
violence ça n'est pas tolérable
certaines dispositions du texte ont
donné lieu à d'âpres échanges notamment
sur l'article premier concernant les
fouilles aux abords des manifestations
une mesure inutile pour les communistes
qui ironisent en réaction à des propos
de christophe castaner si comme moi vous
aviez participé aux dernières
manifestations sous le précédent mandat
contre un gouvernement que vous
défendiez vous auriez su que pour
parvenir aux manifestations nous avons
été systématiquement fouillés
l'article 2 sur la possibilité donnée au
préfet d'interdire une personne de
manifester a cristallisé les tensions
vous créez un nouveau pouvoir
administratif extensif dont nous pouvons
redouter l' arbitraire puisqu'il vise à
interdire à certaines personnes de
manifester et donc de s'exprimer
la gauche qui juge la loi liberticide a
même présenté deux motion de rejet du
texte en début de séance
en vain face aux critiques le ministre
de l'intérieur a lui tenu à rassurer sur
les objectifs de la loi
c'est une loi de protection protection
au pluriel de protection pour les
manifestants qui sont pris en otage par
les casseurs
parce qu'ils cherchent le ko certaine
mesure controversée risque toutefois
d'être annulée avant même cet ultime
vote du sénat
emmanuel macron avait décidé dès lundi
de saisir le conseil constitutionnel
comme le fera la gauche loïc hervé vous
vous avez voté contre ce texte
contrairement à la position de votre
groupe pourquoi j'ai voté pour en
première lecture au sénat et j'ai voté
contre en deuxième lecture au sénat
parce que les modifications apportées
par l'assemblée nationale et le vote
conforme proposé ne correspondait pas
aux valeurs que je défends et à la
question de la proportionnalité des
mesures prises à l'encontre des
manifestations dans l'article 2 qui a
été rédigé à nouveau à l'assemblée
nationale on trouve des prérogatives
donné aux préfets qui sont qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à l'interdiction de
manifester pendant un mois sur
l'ensemble du territoire national pour
moi c'est complètement disproportionné
surtout qu'à aucun moment on ne voit
intervenir un juge donc comme certains
des membres de mon groupe nous avons
voté contre et nous avons fait railler
au sénat pour défendre les libertés
publiques est quelque chose de très
important dans notre pays pourquoi le
sénat ne s'en est pas tenu finalement à
ça a servi version initiale ce que c'est
pas un coup tactique puisque l'on se
rappelle que 50 députés de la majorité
s'était abstenu sur le sur le texte en
première lecture à l'assemblée et
finalement le sénat vote le texte
conforme et le texte va rester en l'état
c'est une manière de piéger la majorité
et emmanuel macron je crois que d'abord
présent la république à koupéla sous le
pied de cette tactique si tactique il ya
en annonçant avant même le vote du sénat
le fait qu'il saisirait le conseil
constitutionnel ce qui est un fait très
rare première fois qu il le fait depuis
qu'il est président la république et
fait très rare si on regarde l'histoire
la vème république
par ailleurs je crois que beaucoup de
sénateurs ont voulu stopper le débat
parlementaire de peur qu'ils prennent
une proportion trop importante donc on a
arrêté le texte tel qu'il a été voté à
l'assemblée nationale on a fait un vote
conforme il va aller devant le conseil
considère et nous verrons ce que
conséquence yonne on dira pour ma part
je pense que sur l'article 2 il y a un
très fort risque de censure du conseil
constitutionnel
finalement on a un texte qui ne
satisfait pas grand monde puisque on a
un texte qui a été à l'origine proposé
par les sénateurs les républicains
ensuite une annonce du premier ministre
qu'il y aurait un texte anti casseurs le
gouvernement reprend ce thème
finalement il ne satisfait pas tellement
la majorité les sénateurs ont l'entente
ont aussi des doutes que va-t-il rester
au final de toutes ces manoeuvres ya
deux choses auxquelles il faut qu'on
veut nous fassions très attention ce
sont les textes d'appel le texte de
première lecture au sénat était un texte
qui faisait suite à civens à notre dame
des landes au 1er mai donc c'est souvent
le l'envi les parlementaires de faire un
texte pour dire on veut répondre à un
problème et deuxièmement notre droit
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme comme
dans la question de l'encadrement des
manifestants sont aidés et déjà un droit
extrêmement nombreux enfin important il
ya beaucoup de dispositions qui existent
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont entre
les mains des préfets entre les mains
des magistrats
donc pour le coup on est dans une
contexte particulier qui suivent
en plus de la crise et gilet jaune ou ce
texte arrive à la au sénat alors qu'il
n'a pas été pensé pour répondre à cela
bon je pense que là le finalement la
décision du sénat permet d'arrêter
l'hémorragie
vous parlez un de cette saisine du
conseil constitutionnel par emmanuel
macron vous vous en êtes quelque peu
étonné en séance quels sens voulu donner
à cette saisine on a vécu avec la sphère
benalla au sénat une période dans lequel
on a beaucoup parlé de la séparation des
pouvoirs et du fait que le parlement et
l'exécutif devait avoir une obsession
réciproque de d'entretenir cette
séparation des pouvoirs est là pour le
coup et c'est pour ça que j'ai fait un
rappel au règlement au début de séance
le président de la république annonce
par le par la voix du porte parole du
gouvernement donc c'est bien l'exécutif
qui le fait c'est pas un communiqué de
presse de l'elysée qu' il y aurait une
saisine du conseil constitutionnel
je trouve que c'est qu'il aurait pu
attendre par par courtoisie que les
parlementaires se positionne que le
débat ait lieu au cénacle vote ait lieu
pour annoncer cela donc ça montre qu'on
est bien dans le champ politique et que
là pour le coup le prénom la république
à jouer
voyons que l'on y aura un vote conforme
à utiliser ce l'article 61 de la
constitution pour dire je me positionne
dans le débat politique
alors le président n'est pas le seul à
avoir décidé de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel au sujet de cette loi
quatre groupes parlementaires à
l'assemblée ont annoncé leur intention
d'en faire de même il s'agit des groupes
socialistes communistes de la france
insoumise et du groupe liberté et
territoires 80 députés en tous
soutiennent ce recours il estime que
cette loi met en danger le droit de
manifester si désormais le président de
la république se pose des questions
c'était pas tout à fait anodin c'est pas
lui qui nous précède c'est plutôt nous
qui l'avons bien précédé dans le la
défense de ses libertés publiques
et encore une fois je vous invite à vous
interroger si se pose lui aussi des
questions
c'est peut-être que encore une fois sur
une démarche inédite de vouloir mettre
une interdiction administrative c'est à
dire décidée par le préfet de manifester
là c'est du jamais vu
évidemment ça va à l'encontre de
l'article 10 et 11 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme
vous soutenez ce recours des
parlementaires lui car je n'ai pas signé
de recours au conseil considère
considérant que d'abord il était fait
l'assemblée nationale par un certain
nombre de pas mal de collègues
parlementaires députés notamment est
conscient que le présent la république
ne l'ayant fait lui-même précisant
d'ailleurs les articles sur lesquels il
porte son recours n'était pas nécessaire
que je m'associe à une démarche de ce
possible en plus et les collègues du duo
centriste au sénat non nous ne sommes
pas 60 pour pour réunir le nombre
nécessaire pro fin au contrat que je
n'ai pas souhaité me mais bien que la
gauche les faits il est fait donc nous
aurons c'est bien que les différents
groupes
y a pas que des groupes gellegos ans il
ya des collègues centristes qui sont qui
ont été interrogés de thaler et donc
pour le coup non jeu on a par contre
j'attends avec impatience de savoir ce
que le conseil va dire sur ce sujet
quand vous pensez que certains articles
vont être alors la joie a validé on ne
connaît pas le les délibérations elles
seront protégées par le secret nous et
puis nous verrons ce qui sera dit je
pensais pas faire moi je pense que vous
le voulez vous lisez l'article l'article
2 notamment l'alinéa 2 de l'article 2
c'est vraiment un droit extrêmement
verbe mal rédigé quand on est sur les
questions de libertés publiques moi je
suis membre de la cnil par ailleurs cédé
sujet quand même qu'il faut qu'ils font
appel à des convictions profondes à
l'histoire et à un cadre juridique
extrêmement précis
c'est vraiment ont par exemple on
utilise le terme d'agissements mais
c'est quoi un agissement vous regardez
la roussane agissements c'est une
intrigue d'une manière d'agir
on va on va les pénaliser ça alors que
le tribunal ne sera même pas saisi fin
c'est juste pour être clair pour finir
sur ce sujet est ce que vous estimez
qu'en votant conforme le sénat n'a pas
joué son rôle de garant des libertés
publiques
non seulement je le pense mais je les
dis je pense que le sénat en votant aux
formes et en disant d'emblée qu'il avait
voté conforme
il a permis au président de la
république de jouer le rôle de garant
des libertés publiques
alors même que la présure parlementaire
n'était pas terminée que c'était bien au
sénat de faire ce rôle là le sénat a
toujours été plus défenseurs des
libertés publiques que l'assemblée
nationale le comme d'ailleurs l'ordre
judiciaire a toujours été plus
défenseurs des libertés publiques que
l'ordre administratif
culturellement traditionnement j'ai bien
que ça souffre de quelques exceptions
dans l'histoire mais la spécificité de
la chambre haute dans le parlement
français c'est bien ça on va passer à
notre deuxième thème les privatisations
âprement débattu cette semaine à
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est une nouvelle fois la
privatisation d'aéroports de paris qui a
été au coeur des débats dans l'hémicycle
repousser un mois plus tôt par le sénat
elle a donc été réintroduite dans la loi
pacte par le gouvernement et donc voter
jeudi soir
mais le ministre de l'économie bruno le
maire a dû batailler ferme face à des
oppositions qui ont fait feu de tout
bois résumé argument contre argument
cinéma était frémont cette nouvelle
lecture devait permettre d'apporter des
garanties pour l'emploi en ile de france
ou encore contre les nuisances sonores
mais elle a finalement tourné au chemin
de croix pour le gouvernement et à un
moment donné le débat tourne en rond ce
qu'on ne veut pas voter ou ne pas voter
on trouve tous les moyens possibles pour
repousser la décision mais soyons
honnêtes
chacun a ses positions mais ne reprochez
pas au gouvernement les gestes de bonne
volonté qu'il veut bien faire pendant
près de neuf heures les critiques de
gauche comme de droite s'enchaînent
c'est une mauvaise opération
aéroports de paris est une entreprise en
plein développement
ma théorie c'est que vous ne voulez pas
être avec emmanuel macron avec votre
gouvernement
ceux qui ont fait passer la dette de la
france
la barre de 100 % du pib devant la
coalition des parlementaires la majorité
elle brocarde une opposition encline à
manier la peur vous agiter des
contre-vérités sur l'ensemble du dossier
oui il est faux de dire que l'état perd
le contrôle de la gouvernance des dp il
est faux de dire aussi que l'état perd
le contrôle des frontières des tarifs
des régulations aéroportuaire et tout
ceci est formalisé dans un cahier des
charges clair rigoureux transparent un
cahier des charges transparent qui n'a
toutefois été dévoilée qu'en plein débat
dans une salle annexe de l'assemblée
de quoi mettre encore un peu plus de
tension au sein de l'hémicycle
cette tragi-comédie qu'on vient de vivre
moi ça fait dix ans je suis député ici
jamais vu ça on nous propose d'avoir
connaissance d'un texte qui nous est
utile pour voter en même temps on va
voter sur le sujet qui concerne ce texte
c'est vraiment du grand n'importe quoi
on suspend les les travaux le temps
nécessaire à le faire et le temps
nécessaire à le faire c'est pas cinq
minutes en catimini
pour pour étudier un document de 100
pages ça c'est pas possible
à l'issue de ce vote une question reste
sans réponse
l'état gardera-t-il des parts dans le
capital d'aéroports de paris
pour bruno le maire toutes les options
de cessions reste sur la table
le hic hervé gauche et droite au sénat
réuni 1 s'était opposé à ces
privatisations il ya un mois vous vous y
êtes favorable pourquoi comme les
membres du groupe centriste du sénat
nous considérons que le métier de la
gestion d'un aéroport les enjeux
d'investissement d'aéroports de paris
le fait que cette entreprise a aussi
vocation à être beaucoup plus présente à
l'international fait que nous sommes
plutôt favorables à cette privatisation
comme certains de mes collègues l'ont
dit hervé marseille vincent
capo-canellas ce qu'ils sont des gens de
la région parisienne et qu'ils ne
connaissent bien le sujet aéroportuaire
est donc celle avantage delà du débat au
sénat ce c'est la plus value que nous
avons pu apporter notamment commission
puis en séance des garanties
supplémentaires pour l'état cette évoqué
en matière de cahier des charges de
procédure pour que l'état garde un
contrôle sur la gestion des aéroports
mais je pense que c'est un vraiment je
redis on le voit on le voit d'ailleurs
dans le monde 7 cette année
c'est un métier particulier et avec des
défis considérables parce que le trafic
aérien a vocation à se développer encore
alors il y avait deux objectifs avec ces
privatisations le désendettement de
l'état et le financement d'un fonds
d'innovation 300 millions est ce qu'il y
avait pas moyen de les trouver plus
facilement autrement d'abord 300
millions c'est peu si nous regardons ce
que font les chinois les américains en
matière d'innovation 300 millions
d'euros cessé même ridicule ceci dit
sont trouvés ils sont fléchés ils vont
au bon endroit parce que dans la période
actuelle
c'est bien qu'ils aient de l'argent
qu'ils soient investis dans ces dans ces
domaines là quant à la réduction de la
dette de l'état c'est indispensable nous
avons nous allons arriver
nous avons dépassé 2 milliards nous
sommes à quasiment 100% du pib
et c'est un vrai enjeu de société que de
désendetter l'état nous sommes trop
endettés on peut pas à nouveau creusé la
dette et on était encore nos enfants
vous parlez des garanties du sénat bruno
le maire a donné de nouvelles garanties
cette semaine
la nonne et s'est notamment assurée de
l'amélioration de la protection des
riverains couvre-feu relie travaux
d'isolation l'état garde la main sur les
tarifs aéroportuaires at il dit est ce
que pour vous ces garanties sont
suffisantes
je crois qu'elles sont importantes elles
sont sans doute insuffisant au sens où
il est nécessaire que sur ces sujets là
et on voit bien la procédure à
l'assemblée nationale que toutes les
informations soit apportée par les écus
tifo parlement pour nos délibérations
dans de bonnes conditions
elles ont visiblement été apportée en
cours de séance je m'en réjouis
donc voilà maintenant il faut il faut
aller de l'avant il faut que cette
transition se fasse elle a été votée à
l'assemblée nationale maintenant je
crois que le texte doit revenir au
scénario en cmp à voir mais c'est donc
une une décision importante qui a été
prise et mais en fait si on regarde la
principale raison pour lesquelles les
parlementaires ont été frileux c'est
l'histoire des autoroutes les autoroutes
ont créé chez les français et chez les
parlementaires des frustrations
considérable avec le sentiment qu'on
avait vendu les bijoux bijoux de famille
et que des entreprises c'est vraiment
faisait beaucoup d'argent sur quelque
chose qui adore du patrimoine national a
aussi un c'est ce que disent les
parlementaires un convent un actif
stratégique on veut un fleuron national
vous ça ne vous inquiète pas c'est la
raison pour laquelle des garanties
supplémentaires ont été demandés au
sénat et visibles ont été apportées à
l'assemblée nationale par le ministre de
l'économie
alors il ya un point qui reste en
suspens est toujours pas si le
gouvernement va vendre l'intégralité de
ses parts ou seulement une partie le
porte parole du gouvernement benjamin
griveaux a dit mardi qu'il pourrait
conserver environ 20%
le ministre bruno lemaire redit que tous
les scénarios sont ouverts vous trouvez
ces hésitations normal ça fait partie
des choses qui dans le débat
parlementaire ne sont plus acceptables
on ne peut pas faire la navette
parlementaire aborder des sujets et
avoir des éléments nouveaux qui arrivent
pendant la séance
et ça c'est une plainte régulière que
nous formulons à l'égard du gouvernement
l'information du parlement pour voter la
loi et quelque chose d'absolument
essentielles sur la question de fond moi
je pense essentiel que l'état gare de
départ dans ce type d'entreprise ne
serait ce que pour avoir une autre
manière de s'exprimer au conseil des
migrations avec la légitimité de
delà d'être au capital et je trouve ça
important évidemment 20% ça me paraît
raisonnable mais ça me paraît nécessaire
que l'état soit soit dans la société
l on en vient à notre troisième thème
quel sort sera réservé au parlement dans
les conclusions du grand débat diminuer
le nombre de parlementaires c'est l'une
des revendications des français dans le
cadre des grands débats emmanuel macron
avait prévu de l'inscrire cette mesure
dans sa réforme des institutions mais à
l'heure de la synthèse du grand débat la
majorité semble moins s'enthousiaste sur
le sujet stéphane à magnan
c'est une revendication qui revient
régulièrement dans le grand débat
notamment dans cette réunion locale dans
les ardennes début février et qui a fait
réagir le député les républicains pierre
cordier la diminution du nombre de
députés et de sénateurs
on va passer par exemple semblerait
qu'on a il parle à 2 577 vous allez bien
dans le département des ardennes
trois cent mille habitants ça va quand
même un peu difficile pour le voir la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
semblait acquise au début du quinquennat
mais force est de constater qu'au sein
même de la majorité en marche à
l'assemblée le doute s'installe
à l'époque les gens disent malheureux
qu'on reverra plus pourra parler à votre
permanence
vous serez plus sur le terrain donc on
se demande où je sens qu'il ya un
consensus pour qu'ils aient moins de
députés
sauf le rôle habite il n'est pas
question renoncé mais ils sont honteux
faut-il voir comment abouti ces
discussions avec le sénat et quels
enseignements il faudra retirer ce que
on aura entendu partout dans le
territoire
la droite sénatoriale avait pourtant
prévenu le gouvernement et se frotte les
mains aujourd'hui craie l'amateurisme
quel amateurisme à en marche ils étaient
les plus fervents partisans de la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
parce que c'était inadmissible et
scandaleux que les 925 députés sénateurs
et maintenant ils disent
oui mais alors revient du grand débat
que la proximité c'est essentiel quand
on peut pas avoir des circonscriptions
de plus de 100000 habitants c'est pas
possible etc
il avait pas besoin de grand débat pour
ça on leur avait dit il ya des mois la
majorité en marche à l'assemblée
pourrait donc revoir sa copie et
effectué 1 re découpage qui permettent
une bonne représentation des territoires
ruraux
c'était une exigence du président du
sénat gérard larcher alors le qu'hervé
est ce vraiment réduisant le nombre de
parlementaires que l'on règlera la crise
de la représentation qui se manifeste à
travers la crise et gilet jaune
j'ai toujours été favorable à la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
considérons que ça permettrait
d'améliorer les conditions de travail à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat et
signé une réduction de nos
parlementaires sans doute je la voterai
mais juste de la question une réduction
de combien qu'elle sert de saison il
faut il faut qu'on aiderait une
réduction c'est des exigences du présent
du sénat gérard larcher kif qui qui sont
fondés sur la présence suffisante de
parlementaires notamment dans les
territoires ruraux où nous avons besoin
d'avoir une vraie représentation à vrai
équilibre au parlement au parlement donc
je crois que c'est c'est dans cette
exigence qu'on doit trouver alors dans
le 1er du présent république c'est un
tiers je crois que aussi si on est entre
entre 20 et et puis ce tir là on
trouvera une solution genre
j'imagine montrant une solution mais en
fait les vraies questions sont quelle
est la place du parlement dans nos
institutions quelles sont les méthodes
de travail du parlement comme on peut
les est ce qu'on peut les améliorer et
comment est ce que on est capable au
parlement de mieux associer nos
concitoyens et les corps intermédiaires
à la fabrication de la loi les enjeux
ils sont pas seulement dans la réduction
du nombre de parlementaires d'ailleurs
souvent elle est présentée comme avec un
intérêt économique
alors qu'on sait que les charges fixes
du palais du luxembourg comme du palais
bourbon sont des charges qui de toute
façon feront que cette réduction sera
finalement assez relative mais comment
on fait pour améliorer parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a vu pendant le grand débat
en entendant les français que les
parlementaires ont mauvaise image alors
souvent il y à une mauvaise
compréhension de leur travail certes
mais comment vous faites pour améliorer
l'image des parlementaires et comment
vous l'expliquez cette mauvaise image
je vous l'expliqué jeu
convaincu que dans toutes les périodes
de crise l'anti l'antiparlementarisme
comme d'ailleurs d'autres prurit de
s'exprime et donc l'antiparlementarisme
c'est très régulier chaque fois que le
pays est en crise on dit c'est il faut
bien qu'il y ait un coupable donc on le
trouve au parlement alors que l'on
pourrait s'interroger
eh bien j'ai été très surpris dans le
grand débat qu'on parle pas du tout du
fonctionnement de l'exécutif fonction de
cabinet ministériel il fonctionnement
des administrations des auffes de nombre
de hauts fonctionnaires de gens qui ont
le pouvoir aussi dans notre pays et qui
sont finalement beaucoup moins mis sur
la sellette que que nous le sommes
et donc c'est vraiment une question qui
moi m'inquiète en tant que sénateur dans
un département qui est à 4 heures de
paris de voir comment est-ce qu'on peut
à la fois garder un lien important avec
le territoire et au sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale faire un travail
de représentation de juste
représentation les internautes être et
ça c'est une vraie en jeu j'ai une plus
grande réserve que que d'autres
personnes dans mon groupe seraient qui
sont la proportionnelle parce que je
pense qu'elle va malheureusement ajouter
des parlementaires urbain à l'assemblée
et que c'est pas forcément ce dont nous
avons le plus besoin
alors en attendant peut-être des
changements plus importants dans la
foulée du grand débat le président de
l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
annoncé plusieurs réformes cette semaine
elle concerne fonctionnement du parler
du palais bourbon dans la traditionnelle
et très médiatique séance de questions
au gouvernement
les précisions de match des moulins
rénover la vie parlementaire c'est
l'ambition affichée par le président de
l'assemblée nationale dans une lettre
adressé aux 577 députés richard ferrand
détail les transformations qu'il entend
impulser au palais bourbon
parmi elles la réforme des
traditionnelles questions au
gouvernement de deux séances
hebdomadaires aujourd'hui le mardi et le
mercredi il n'y en aurait plus qu'une
seule le mercredi richard ferrand
souhaite aussi qu'elle dure deux heures
contre une heure actuellement avec une
nouveauté la mise en place d'un droit de
réponse comme au sénat pour dynamiser
les échanges ainsi ministres et députés
pourrait répliquer autant qu'ils le
souhaitent dans la limite
deux minutes de temps de parole par
personne autre annonce du président de
l'assemblée nationale sa volonté de
revivifier le droit de pétition
les propositions qui recueilleront
suffisamment de signatures de citoyens
pourront automatiquement donné lieu à un
débat en séance
mais à ce stade richard ferrand ne
précise ni le seuil ni les conditions de
son déclenchement
enfin le président de l'assemblée
nationale veut également resserré les
horaires des séances à l'assemblée
objectif que les débats de nuit ne
dépasse plus minuit contre une heure du
matin actuellement est parfois bien plus
alors loïc hervé ce droit de réponse
pendant les questions au gouvernement le
sénat le pratiquent déjà c'est une
formule qui a fait ses preuves selon
vous cela apporte vraiment quelque chose
ça marche plutôt bien
à la condition que le collègue
parlementaire n'est pas rédigé la
réplique avant de rentrer dans la
tendance en séance
je le dis amicalement mais je pense que
ça ça nécessite que la question initiale
soit rédigé sa logique mais que la
réplique à doit être beaucoup plus
naturelle et elle doit permettre
d'interpeller mise sur sa non réponse ou
les parties de deux chutes du sujet qui
doivent être creusés à nouveau la ccsa
envoyé une vraie une vraie un vrai
échange message est passé à vos
collègues sénateurs autre point le droit
de pétition que richard ferrand souhaite
renforcer gérard larcher avait dit la
même chose il y a quelques semaines ils
disent que si un certain nombre de
citoyens alors sans donner précisément
le nombre signer une pétition elle doit
donner un débat parlementaire c'est une
bonne chose pour vous je me méfie
énormément des débats parlementaires
nous avons des semaines de contrôle du
gouvernement qui ont des semaines où
nous nous organisons des débats et le
parlement parle
et pendant qu'il parle il n'accomplit
pas sa vraie mission pour moi la mission
du parlement en termes de contrôle
c'est d'être beaucoup plus présent sur
des éléments de faits sur le terrain et
à la rencontre des problématiques des
acteurs et organiser un débat entre
quelques parlementaires le jeudi après
midi sur un sujet même s'il vient de nos
compatriotes c'est quelque chose qui me
paraît pas forcément inutile
merci beaucoup le carré d'avoir été
notre invité cette semaine marc citti
beau et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]